hello hello okay there we go now we're
on there oh my god
things are going like really crazy um
i'm supposed to be streaming with hikaru
and
things have just gone completely nuts so
i'm trying to get
connected now let's see what we've got
here
all right we've got that going and then
in the meantime
we've got to get twitch going here it's
just crazy oh very
hey hikaru oh my god dude i'm so sorry i
had this for 6 45
and then i saw your message and i was
like oh my god i'm the guy who's always
on time
okay okay
yeah no problem i'm live by the way just
in case you were about to say something
horrible
okay that's that's fair
oh and people can't even hear you on my
stream so i'm gonna fix that and then
we're gonna be just beautiful all right
now you guys should be able to hear him
right there we go okay wow
wow all right wait a second
it should be pretty good oh you're like
you're super professional
thank you well i'm 15 minutes late which
is not the most professional thing but
that's that that's a very valid point
make sure okay i think you look pretty
good let me just
make sure
okay
all right i think we are good to go so
beautiful sure okay
all right um so
what's that we're we're live right right
right
um yeah so i guess first and foremost
you're
what is your background with chess i
tend to ask a lot of people before i
give them uh give them lessons
well it's an ugly background it's um i
mean basically
i just got into it like a year and a
half ago
and i'm not getting any better but i
enjoy it
and i've taken a few lessons here and
there and then
somehow i'm in a tournament later this
month and
it could be horribly embarrassing for me
well i what i would say first and
foremost is that actually out of all the
players that i've seen you're one of the
early favorites
really i didn't know that there was a
there was a line on this
i would say there's an official line but
from what i've seen there's certain
people who have more experience like
when you say that you just start a year
ago and you're not improving
you're one of the better players that
i've seen so far just your general
understanding of um
of the game oh my god
i don't know what that says about me or
the competition
well i think everyone has a different
kind of way of picking up the game some
people pick it up quicker than other
people
is what i would say you know what i was
going to ask you was
as a grand master if you meet an adult
who just isn't very good at chess and
like
you show them a few things and they're
not getting any better
do you question their general
intelligence like does somebody like you
see any chess ability at all as a proxy
to general intelligence
um i in general i don't think that i
view it that way
what i would say is that in order to be
good at chess you have to have a certain
um let me invite you use this board
first um is that you have you have to
have a certain
sort of knack for spatial sort of
spatial recognition
like spatial recognition or just pattern
general pattern recognition
in order to be good at chess so if
someone is not improving at chess
i wouldn't necessarily say that that
means they're um
they're they're not they're not smart
because there's there are a couple of
people i know
um for example there's there's this
professor i know
at princeton and he's about like 16 1700
um but he's been working on string
theory for a very long time but he's
been stuck at this rating
for probably the last like 10 years i
think at least and he hasn't been
improving
but he's obviously a very smart guy
outside of chat so i don't tend to
look at it from that standpoint of like
if you're not good at chess you're
you know you're stupid that's just not
how i do it i think um
like critical thinking and spatial
spatial awareness and pattern
recognition are important
but i don't think that's what makes you
smart or not smart so i don't tend to
think
think like that that's good so maybe if
i implode during the tournament it won't
necessarily kill my political analysis
career no i think
i'm trying i'm trying not to say
anything to too off the cuff but what i
would say is that in terms of politics i
think uh
it would be nice if um if there were
more people who did
play games like chess who did use
critical thinking and they they were
logical in their approach
uh to politics instead of sort of to
just say
say anything you want to say and not
have a deep deep understanding or
or reasoning behind what they're saying
that makes sense to me
um and just like this isn't really
political per se but one thing that i
found very interesting is that if you go
back in
in history uh i believe the first like
five or six u.s presidents all played
chess um george washington played chess
thomas jefferson did i think james
madison was an avid cosplayer and even
benjamin franklin he played a lot of
chess when he was in paris as
as the ambassador for the us uh to
france
so i don't i don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing but i've always
thought that's kind of interesting when
you look at it
from the political standpoint well it
seems like probably at the time
a cultured gentleman was expected to
play chess right i mean that's really
changed now
if you say to me uh hey the governor of
florida
is is 2200 i would say there's no way
that that's the case just looking at the
guy and hearing him talk
but he's not a cultured gentleman in the
way that some of these old-time
politicians were
yeah i i feel like there's a lot that i
could say about the governor of florida
that i will try to refrain um but yeah
certainly i think in the old days it was
considered one of those things that they
they looked at as being a game
that really it was sort of up upper
class for say something a lot of people
were smart they played it when
when they um if they call they were
cultured they would play the games
right it certainly used to be true
nowadays i think chess still has that
but um it's it's not
i don't know i think there are a lot of
other things people can do
i think that's a beautiful way to say it
yeah
um but but it's one of those games that
a lot of people
uh a lot a lot of very smart scientists
mathematicians used to play
and also when you look at some of the
really strong chess players going back
like 30 to 40 years
they were able to excel in fields
besides just so like they're one of the
world chess champions
um vasily smithslav from russia he was
also a professional musician
on top of being the world champion of
chess and
another world champion mikhail bot vinik
also russian uh who was instrumental in
sort of developing the russian school
and the russian approach to chess he he
also was a computer engineer computer
scientist
and involved with some of the earliest
computer chess programs
what's your sense not to get off track
because i know we have big training to
do but
what's your sense of like correct me if
i'm wrong but it seems as though
somewhere between early to mid or
sometimes late 30s
the top chess players start to decline
and i saw your video looking at you know
the top-ranked chess players over time
and you know so on and so forth
you would think that it's not like
basketball we're like we understand why
when you're 35 you're all of a sudden
not going to be quite as good right
there's it's sort of a different sort of
thing
what is the limitation that starts to
drag players down at 35 to 38 is it that
the long form games you might be
thinking about a move intensely for
90 minutes and that you become your
stamina is what starts to get you
yeah so basically the biggest difference
is is um what technology has changed for
the game so if you go back
let's say pre-1995 because i would say
95
is when computers really started getting
good to the point where we could learn
from them
um if you go back before then due to the
sort of
lack of technology a lot of players
could play openings for their entire
career so imagine for example that you
play
i believe you play the diana opening
with white to say i play it is a bit of
a stretch but let's go with it yeah
so like if you play the vienna opening
and you just accumulate years and years
of experience of playing it from when
you were very young as a child
you could probably play out opening your
entire career because the lack of
information the lack of
sort of knowledge that people had on the
openings and the games the players were
playing
meant that you could play openings for
your whole career and that experience
the accumulation of it
it would mean that you become better and
better as you age
but nowadays what happens is that
because of the technology first of all
every game you played
play can be analyzed um by your
opponents and secondarily with the
computers
someone can probably know whether your
opening approach
is good or bad within five minutes if
they just open the computer engines and
they study the game within five minutes
they will know if what you played is
good or bad and so
nowadays as you're getting better you're
playing more and more you have to keep
coming up with new ideas
and you have to use more energy at the
board whereas before
it was much more sort of you just you do
your preparation and you just
the game is uh game is very interesting
at the start and someone makes a blunder
early now people don't make blunders
because of the influence of computers
and so the games get decided deeper and
deeper
which in turn means you use more and
more energy both away from the board
and at the board in order to um in order
to try and win and
and get better and so that's why in the
mid to late 30s
the best players tend to start to
decline yes because now because in the
old days i think
the peak of chess players was probably
in their mid 30s actually it was
probably mid 30s and you could play
until you were
probably i would say around late 40s
maybe even up into the early 50s a
couple of the world champions were still
very competitive till then
but nowadays um because the amount of
effort the work you have to put in
before the game and then during the game
it's just the stamina and you don't
think of chess as being being like
physical but you do have to be in pretty
good shape so when you think about the
competitions you're studying five hours
a day you play a game that's another
five to six hours
um you do this for weeks on end as
you're getting older it takes more and
more energy
right i saw uh this
crazy interview with the notorious
anti-semite
bobby fischer on the dick cavett show
years ago
and far be it for me to
defer to an anti-semite on anything but
one of the things he seemed to say in
his kind of haze of paranoia
was that he seemed frustrated that chess
became about
just who has memorized further into a
game like
you know first five moves 10 15 20 25
and then it basically just became a
memorization contest and that seemed to
be part of what made him lose interest
as well as he seemed to want to focus
more on researching conspiracies about
jews
yeah so so what i would say about about
fisher is there a couple things first of
all he
he sort of foresaw what you have in
modern day chess with
a lot of the memorization techniques
being used in the opening phase of the
game
but what i would say is one of the one
one of the things that's very beautiful
about
chess is that there are some tournaments
that are going on right now featuring
top chess players and there was a game
yesterday in one of these events
where the world champion and another
player was in the top 10 played and i'll
move
move uh actually wasn't the world
champion but i'm like move seven of the
game
they had a new position that had never
been seen before in the entire history
of chess
and that was on move seven so yes there
is a lot of uh memorization
there they're just that's what openings
are these days but still there is a lot
of creativity and room for new ideas
um especially because with the new
program alpha zero the the deepmind
google project
you're seeing computers sort of play the
game a little bit differently and so
we're trying to learn
from some of the things that they're
doing um some of the strategies they're
employing and trying to use that in our
own games
that that makes a lot of sense um and
then just like in general
i would also say um i i had a
conversation
i think this was shortly after fischer
died if i remember correctly um i was at
the marshall chess club in new york city
and
and dick cavett he he was there at the
time and i spoke briefly
with briefly with him on this topic and
he seemed to be under the impression
that basically fischer won his
and went insane because of the pressure
of the of sort of the system playing
against the soviets
um mainly mainly just like all the
pressure it just built up and he kind of
exploded unfortunately yeah it's uh
certainly seemed to be
so yeah it's i never had a chance to
meet fisher obviously i wish i wish i
had but
um it's it's hard to know what the
realities realities are but
it's it's it's what it is i guess it
certainly
is yes uh so from the standpoint of this
tournament
i mean what what needs to be you know
it's like
different people i've been working with
we look at some openings as white we
look at a strategy as black that maybe
does or doesn't depend on what my
opponent plays everybody can see what
everybody's being taught right like
my future opponents could be watching
this stream and so on and so forth so
do i need more theory
general ideas or do i need specific
openings so i think some of the openings
that i've seen that you play
are pretty standard and and it's
it's not about memorization see that's
that's one of the things that i think
makes
is interesting like to use one of the
things that i love about chess is the
way you can extrapolate it into other
other fields of life and so like one one
thing is when i look at chess in terms
of education very specifically
and and with chess there is no set
method of learning
for one person like certain people get
really good from just like memorizing
looking over and over at the same things
other people learn from playing
other people learn from doing puzzles
everyone sort of has a different method
of learning and so
like what i what i intend to show you is
not not the openings because i think you
already
you already have pretty good grasp on
them and that's not where you're going
to win
win the games once you're in the
champions championship bracket um
maybe i'm maybe i'm putting my hopes too
high on you already by saying the
championship bracket but i do expect you
to be in the top eight
holy [ __ ] so so so
what i would say is that like it it's
more about like knowing the middle games
than
end games like i want to show you some
end games so this sort of stuff that if
you get it down like if you know what to
do with the concepts
you will see some of these things start
to occur in the games when you're
matched up against players of the same
same rating range or the same strut
right like in the board we're looking at
now it seems i need to avoid a stalemate
right that's the strategy to avoid
stalemate
right so this is king and pawn against
king this is one of the most basic and
games very few pieces on the board
now this end game is winning um winning
for white but i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you
just a basic start so let's just say you
push the pawn okay
you can make moves as well um so let's
say black moves the king
you where would you what would you play
as white i think i'd probably move the
king up
right and so now if i go here
okay so do you know what the what the
result of this position would be with
the king and the pawn versus the king
um well i mean i guess i'd want to not
get
i i want to avoid these squares because
then i lose the pawn so i'd be looking
at one of these two
um and then the king would have to um
move away i think and then i would move
up
and then just kind of try to start
pushing the king back correct so you
want to use the king of the pawn and you
want to escort the pawn up the board to
make a queen now the problem with this
with um with this position is it's
actually a draw
because i what's the law how do you try
to
proceed to get this pawn to the end of
the board right i mean i guess
right
and so do you see what's going to happen
here right
so this is a draw now if we if we go
back one move let's say we get to
um uh let me just make make it wrong
with let me say i move my king here
instead of
staying um saying uh basically
opposite the pawn is white can now go
here and when the king goes here you
push the pawn and white's winning
right because now my king has to move
and then what's your next
uh right and you make a queen i assume
you know how to mate with the king and
queen
um i think so uh maybe we should still
review it
okay so all right
so try to make the checkmate uh so let's
see i think that there's some idea where
i want to basically like create a
smaller and smaller box for the king
right
for the yeah for the for the opposing
king so i guess here i'd go here
okay
okay
good
i often end up in stalemate here so now
i have to think ahead
um
that now that that's yeah cell mate
right that's the that was the mistake
so what you want to do is like when you
get the king to like this square for
example
you can go between um actually instead
of here you can go queen here
okay and once you get the basically the
king is cut off right it can't it can't
come up to the second rank it's stuck
here
between these two two squares what you
want to do is when the king gets the
corner and they're only two squares
then you bring the king and then you
make the checkmate
got it and it's actually the same like
even if the king is here
for example you can also cut it off like
this you see how it's now cut off this
way
yeah it has these two squares so when
the king goes here you go here
here and make the checkmate so the idea
is
at some point restrict the king either
horizontally or vertically
to to just one rank or file and then
move my king up until the checkmate move
right basically you want to get the king
to where it only has these two corner
squares
right where it can only go to these two
or or these two and then you bring the
king and you just meet on like this this
square
right with the king and the queen so it
seems like more or less you do have it
you should you should have it down it
doesn't seem like uh
i i don't know do you want to try to do
it again let's let's see if you can do
it um
from this position um let's go here okay
okay um
hmm
so now okay so now i would be at the
point where i want to make sure you
don't get beyond
the second rank right now one thing you
can also do is you can also use your
queen to force the king to the corner as
well
in this position yeah so so how is there
a way you can force the king to the edge
of the board
like horizontally or vertically to the
last last ring
um would it be maybe
oh no that doesn't make sense um with a
queen move now
maybe here right now so do you see what
happens when you move the queen here the
king
kind of it only has three squares so
let's say i go to this square
yep i think i would start moving the
king in
you can but you know what else you can
do here you can also go here
uh okay right but and so now there are
three squares
um so it's not quite to the very corner
but what you can do after this move is
you can move the king
i move my king and how do you force the
king to the final two corner squares
um i think i for now i keep moving my
king in
yeah you can move your k yeah actually
it doesn't matter that's fine if that's
what works best then
that's fine so okay and when i go here
um
i think i move the king and again
and then now here right and let's check
me so
yeah you clearly it's not not super hard
for you you understand
cutting off the king vertically or
horizontally and and when you play queen
d3 let's say go this way
how do you cut off the king here um so
here right exactly
and then now now i start moving the king
in
you yeah but if you do but actually you
don't want to go down here you want to
go up because
here what happens is in this position
your king can't come over
i got it so what you want to do is um in
this position you bring the king up and
around like this
got it like this
right and that's checkmate so that's
good i just i just want to make sure
to see that you had the king and queen
mate down but you clearly do
so let's go back to this now let's go
back to the starting position we
established that this position with the
king in front of the pawn like this is
going to be a draw right
yep so the main thing is let's say
you're on the defending side
what you need to remember is that when
the pawn gets to this the sixth rank
where it's
it's two squares away from pointing you
keep the king
opposite you keep the king right in
front of the pawn you don't go to one of
the sides if you're defending
you keep the king right in front of it
and then whichever way i go with my king
up to the one of these squares you
always you always uh go to the side
the king is here so go like over and if
i go here where would you go
right so so yeah you just keep it
opposite and then when i check you come
over so
my next move means it's a draw got it
so back to start so obviously if you
push this pawn up the board i'm just
going to keep my king in front of the
pawn and this is going to be a draw
so yes it is this is where there's a way
that you can actually win this game by
force
and so the way that you win is actually
something that's not very intuitive
because normally you just want you think
you push the pawn up the board and make
a queen right
yeah i mean i'm guessing it would either
be e3 to start or maybe moving the king
first
yeah so it's it's not it's not a pawn
move what it is is you bring the king up
which okay of course yeah why not move
the king up that seems pretty
straightforward but
the way that you win here is by br by
using the king and bringing it in front
of the pawn
got it because then it prevents the king
from actually getting
close enough to the pawn right
so i want to see if you can right and
now so i'm going to go here
i mean okay i guess this would be my
instinct but maybe there's some other
trick
so i go here okay so now do i move in
the same direction as the king or the
opposite direction
maybe same direction you could do that
but actually if you do this i just go
back
oh okay and the problem here is now if
you push the pawn we're in the same
position again
right where we're going to end up where
you push the pawn i just keep the king
straight on these
keep going right i can't i can't get the
king back in front of the pawn
right so what you do here is actually
you go the other way you go king here
okay so now let's say i bring my king up
i want to see if you can figure out how
to win this position for white
how you can push the pawn up the board
use the king of the pawn and go straight
up the board and make a queen
okay so i'm guessing it's one of these
two moves that i'm i'm looking for i
guess the quilts let's see
okay so now i'm going to go here and now
this is blocked
so maybe that was the wrong one no no
it's the right move
oh it is do i mean do i do this again
okay that doesn't seem to make sense
oh okay okay so now i'm gonna go here
um okay so if i go here
the king can't access this square so
maybe that's okay
but do you see what's gonna happen now
it's that same position from before
right and so it's a draw yeah so
what you do here is you don't actually
push the pawn you move the king over
okay so
okay the problem here is do you see
what's gonna happen what happens if i go
here
now i go this way right and i can never
stop your pawn from queening
right because your king guards all three
of these squares that you're gonna
you're just gonna push the pawn up the
next three squares
and and i can't i can't stop that got it
because when i go here you just push i
go here you just push and you make the
queen because the king guards all the
critical squares
and it's it's winning and so on this
path up the board
it seems like it was was it here and
this so we have a term for this and it's
called the it's called the opposition
okay which is basically like the kings
you see the see how the kings are
opposite each other right here
so what you want is in this position you
want it where when it's the opposition
your opponent
who who only is the king and they move
whichever way they go
you go the other direction got it so so
in the in this position if it's if it's
white's move this is actually a draw
and the reason it's a draw is because
when i go here um
actually wait if i if i um let me just
make a couple random moves
um is that the reason this is a draw
is because of its white's move and i go
here how do you where do you move to
keep the opposition with the king
as black yes oh i mean i can flip the
board too i guess
um i mean i guess you go here
well there's over here i said keep the
opposition
so how do you keep the opposition here
oh you want to so so i guess here
right and so do you see what happens if
in this position
um if it's if it's white's move
black always has the opposition where
the kings remain opposite opposite each
other and
wherever i go like even if i go this way
you go the same directions
king you keep the opposition and then
once i push the pawn how do you
how do you draw the end game um
back here and right and so now i can't
get my king in front of the pawn so i
have to push here
and then back here remember what i said
when the king is in front of the pawn
you want to keep the king
oh right right right right so then just
back
right and when i go here
so to get the opposition well okay if
you go here what is white's next move
though
um i guess here
that works but but this is the the
correct move oh okay putting the king in
front right okay
right and then whichever way the king
goes you you go up one square and then
you put
push the pawn and make a queen again yep
so as white i want to be going in the
opposite direction as black you want to
be basically staying in front of the
pawn
as much as possible yeah you want to
keep the opposition the kings
opposite each other when you can't yeah
so like in this position you
always want to keep the king here got it
and so when i push the pawn
what's the next move right
and now remember now now that you have
to move the king back
right so this is the point now when i go
here
right keeping the opposition keeping the
kings opposite each other
um and so this is just a draw now
right so because here and then here
right or wait sorry what was that
so so it would be yeah right and then
white has to go over and it's a draw
yep so let's go back to the start let's
let's see if you can win this with white
okay um so first king right
so i'm gonna move my king
um the problem with this is now right
now i'm putting the king in front first
i'm putting the king in front
right so now i'm just gonna move my king
yep
uh okay so i want to go the opposite way
right
right okay so now i'm going to try to
keep the opposition i'm going to try to
keep my king opposite your king
okay so now i play pawn
that's fine and i go here i put the king
back in front
right and so now again i have to move so
i can't keep the opposition i have to
move my king i can't keep the king ops
at your king
right okay so i'll go here
um what you need to do here is actually
move the king over first
oh okay because if you move the pawn i
now move my king and i get the
opposition again
okay okay right so what you do is you
move the king and now again i have to
move my kings i can't i can't keep the
keep the opposition right now here do i
go pawn or do i move my king again
well remember you don't want to push the
pawn because then i can go back and i
get the opposite oh it's the same
position right okay
so here right and so now let's say go
here okay that's a good question
so now the opposition is from the side
now so it's not the same opposition so
yeah you do well if i move my pawn here
i think i lose the pawn right or maybe
not no
do i move back well remember the goal is
you want to get the pawn to the under
the board
yeah so what you actually should play is
you should push the pawn
okay so now i'm going to go back
now i go back in front not yet
you still can push the pawn okay and so
now what happens if i go king here
okay so let's see then i'm controlling
these so you have to end up somewhere
here
but remember at the end of the day where
do you ideally want your king remember
you want to get it you want to get a
queen
well eventually it's going to have to be
to the side of this
file right and which which square
controls all the critical um
squares whether you can put your king on
a square
right because i i can't attack the pawn
right and so now when i go here
right right and you're just going to
make a queen next move yep
so basically what you what you want to
do is um at the start of this
when you bring this king up at a certain
point black is going to try to keep the
opposition where the kings are opposite
each other
and when you reach the um when you reach
this opposition
what you do here is to break it is now
you can play the waiting move with the
pawn
so now my king has to move i can't keep
my king opposite your king the way i
would like to
right and whichever way i go you go the
other way right
and so and again if i come up here
what's your next move
uh pond i come back
i think here right and so now i go back
right and now when i go to the back rank
now i go in front
no over and when i go here
right and now again your king gets the
critical square on this side
and the pawn is just going up the board
yep yep
so so again this is this is the
opposition now this this probably won't
happen much but it's important to
remember not so much
because of the specific end game but
this this this uh
idea that you can get your king where it
can escort the pawn all the way up
right because this will likely happen in
in a couple of your games if you reach
an end game
yep where like you'll have a king and
you'll need to use the king
a lot to squirt the pawn up the board
and so the thought process i need to be
thinking of
is which squares do i which three
squares do i eventually want to control
so that the opposing king can't stop my
pawn right
exactly so let's let's try it from the
start let's see if you can win this
against me
okay uh king
um i think in front
right
so now i'm trying to keep the opposition
again
okay so now i think now it's pawn still
okay so i go here i think it's pawn
again
no but remember again when there's the
opposition so
let's let's do it this way the easiest
way to remember this
is here move the king over and put the
king two squares where the pawn where um
where the pawn has sorry put the king on
e4 where you have one square for the
pawn okay
right so because i'm trying to create
the opposition so put the king here
and then when you have the opposition um
on the same file that this pawn is here
now what's your next move now i push the
pawn
right and so now when i go here
then here right and so now okay so now
i'm going to go back
pawn so now i'm trying to get the
opposition or wait no not not pawn sorry
um
what you need to do here is you always
need to keep this keep a spot
okay got it
so how do you right and so now i have to
go over
and now remember you don't want to let
me get the opposition here
because my idea is right and so now when
i come up to try and get towards your
pawn
right so i go back
right and now so i you forced me back to
this back rank
right and now exactly and again you just
push this pawn all the way up the board
and you make it clear
so this is not super super intuitive or
easy but i think it's important to try
and remember this this notion
of um getting the king using the
opposition of where when your opponent
when
when your opponent is trying to keep the
opposition with the two kings opposite
each other
if you you don't you don't want to get
into a spot where it's say like this
if it's this move and it's it's white's
move it's a draw right
yeah because you can never get the king
off to the side and use the king of the
pawn
to go up the board right so
the so i'm i'm not explaining this very
well but
it's essentially all about the
opposition here like it you what you
want is you want this position
where you can you can keep the king in
front of pawn force the king off to one
of the sides where the king cannot keep
the opposition
and then you escort the pawn of the
board now if my opponent doesn't know
what they're supposed to be doing to
play this perfectly
then what does my strategy become just
to move the pawn up
if if the king is not one move away from
doing their idea for example let's say i
put my king
king back here uh yep or let me let me
say i leave my king right here
you would you would still use the same
strategy you want to bring you want to
keep the pawn back to where you
so you can always push it at the
critical moment when your opponent tries
to get opposition so let's say okay
here um i'm just going to make a random
move like this
what you would do is again you can play
um you can go king here to keep the
opposition
right and now your opponent has to move
the king
right so when he moves the king it
doesn't matter here because it like if
you if you go up
um i just come here and then if you push
i come up and i'm threatening to win the
pawn
right but here there are two squares to
push the pawn so what you would do here
is you push again
and when your opponent goes back to get
the opposition you push again
that's now the king has to move off and
then what's the next move
right and you just push the pawn next
three moves make the queen
and then you'll make the checkmate now
is there some
like if my opponent's not playing this
perfectly is there some imaginary box
where i don't want the pawn getting more
than a certain distance from the king
because then i could get into trouble
um generally they're what i would say is
what you want is you want to keep the
distance um
probably not more than two to two
squares apart okay here there are two
squares between
because if they're more squares between
like for example let's say you go here
um then like then if you try to push the
pawn you'll see that it's still winning
but you have to you have to bring your
king back to push the pawn up so you
have to waste some moves so i would say
like not more than two
try to keep it as two squares between
them makes sense
um okay so let me open a new board is
this
this is gonna be the same concept but
slightly different
um i don't know was that do you kind of
understand that
yeah yeah i mean i've gotten into
situations not so much with this but
certainly like where i end up
stalemating with rook and king or stuff
like that where it's useful to think
through this
okay so i'm gonna bring up another
position um let me invite you to this
board
okay so you should have gone the invite
i think to this this board as well
yep okay
um all right so so you see this position
this is again king and pawn versus uh
versus king and pawn
now one thing well i'll make the first
one because the first one is pretty
pretty obvious for what you want you
want to bring the king up and how how
would you how would you win this game
let's just say i keep moving on the side
um okay i mean i guess in theory i would
try to
uh try to kind of escort the pawn up
but keeping it aware keep of this pond
so that i don't end up losing the pond
like for example i
i wouldn't move the pond right now
because then i just lose the pond right
so what you would do is notice where the
kings are this black king is much
further away from both the black pot
and the white pawn so i might just try
to use my king to capture the pawn and
then turn it into the last
situation how would you try to capture
the pod i guess maybe here
okay so now i probably want to start
moving this way
right but actually okay so if you go
here i'm going to go king here
so now think about the previous position
what happens if you push this pawn
so like when you push the pawn my king
goes here yep
it's the same it's the same draw
position from before right
right and why is it why is it a draw uh
because i
can never force your king away right my
king gets the opposition
you have to move your king um whereas
your opponent does not have to move
their king
right so what you would do here is you
would actually go king here
okay that's now when i go king here
um pond i go here to get the opposition
okay so i don't want to push the pawn
because then we've got that draw
situation
but it's not your move so actually black
has to break the opposition not white
like when you push the pawn it's not
your it's not your turn
so when you push the pawn it's my turn
and i have to make a move
okay so then when i move my king
right yeah exactly and now okay right so
you win the game
so it seems pretty easy and
straightforward right yes
so sorry okay
um all right so so what i'm going to say
is when black brings the king closer if
you get your king up where you capture
the pawn
we've established this is just winning
right now one question about this
position am i actually better off going
behind the pawn
in order to capture the black pawn uh
you actually kind of are so so let's say
let's say i go here
and let's for for for the purpose of
this example
now when you move your king here i'm
going to push my pawn
okay i guess in this case i would just
push my pawn
why would you not capture this font all
right that's a good question
uh i i actually i'm not sure okay so the
position i put is slightly wrong because
in this case when you capture the pawn
you do win
because if i go king here you can just
push this pawn up the board it might be
right it doesn't get over in time um
but just for the the example of this
this puzzle the pawn is on the very edge
of the board here
so if you push the pawn up the board my
king is in time to get over and capture
it
right so in this position
based on what i showed you before how
would you assume that you can win this
position
um starting with a king move okay
so you move your king and i'm gonna move
my king here
um okay so my goal is to get my king in
front of the pawn you can't really stop
me from getting the king over here
right so do i put my king in front of
the pawn
or go in a different direction so what
you would think should work is to put
the king in front right
that would probably be my instinct right
so now we're going to reach this
position here
now let's say you go king here and i go
here you can push the pawn to break the
opposition
because now my king has to move yes
there's only one problem
which is what happens when my king moves
over
um well i only have two moves
and i don't know that either of them is
good actually wait hold on if i go here
though now i'm controlling these three
squares and my oh no i'm not yet
controlling that square
so what you really want here is in this
position is you would like to be able to
move your king off the board you'd like
to move it to the right
up one square and then escort the pawn
to the end of the board
beautiful but you can't do that there's
no extra file here
right that's the so when you get the
pawn on the very edge of the board like
this
none of the rules with the opposition
apply anymore because your king can only
go this way to the left
there's there's no extra there's no
extra square there's no square on i7
your king can't go off the board um
so so maybe back then i should not have
captured the pawn
right exactly and so the point is that
when you reach this end game
um you need to be very aware that when
you get pawns on the very edge of the
board on either this h file or this a
file
if you can push the pawn all the way
down the board and make a queen that's
great but if your opponent can get their
king over
then it's a draw it's always a draw and
what's the calculation for whether the
king can make it is it a three by three
box
um it's just literally do the
calculation of how many squares it takes
so like here the way you would do it is
like you see one
two three four five six
um and you see it's one two three four
so because it takes
because it's uh it's four and actually
let's say i go here it's it's one two
three four right
yep and it's one two three four five
so the king does not get over in time so
it's five now it was four and four the
king would get over
yep but it's it's it's five um and
it it's five so like let's say it's
black moved here it's uh
let me just make a random move here you
see it's one two three four so it's
white's move it's one two three four so
the king gets over when the number is
either
yeah but in this case it's it's one two
three four
five and white moves first so because
white moves first then it's one two
three versus one two three four
five right so like five minus four
equals one
um in terms of the square like what i
would say is uh
when when it depends like let's say here
it's four square c on the board if the
king is
um what's the king here king here
king here it's four to the end but it's
also four over so
when it's the same number over as the
number of squares to push the pawn then
the king will get over in time
yes so i don't know if that makes sense
yeah so so that's why yeah when i push
the pawn you can push the pawn up here
and when i bring my king over how would
you win this
uh i think maybe now i head here okay
mm-hmm
right and so now when i go here
right i go here here
when i move here right you move the king
up and you're going to make a queen and
you're going to win the game
yep so that one actually i thought would
be a little bit harder but
it's not super hard so now let's do
another one this should be
this is more like conceptual than um
then then like specific calculation but
this this also i think is is a famous
one so one second let me just pull this
up as well
all right now do you have this stuff
saved or do you literally just build it
on the fly
um i can i can build it on the fly but i
do have these concepts they're
basically you know burned into my memory
so like i just
i i do know this by heart oh yeah no i
just meant in terms of like sharing it
are you actually putting a board oh yeah
yeah because what i'm doing to put this
up is i'm basically taking a file from
from chess software and um and and i'm
creating it so yeah i can definitely
share it with you afterwards
got it okay so this is um this is this
is a position where it's whites move
here
so it's again king and pond versus king
and pawn and this this is very famous
because of the
uh there's there's a gary kasparov
master class and he actually goes over
this specific one and i know it's in the
trailers everywhere
so everyone has seen this but it's
white's move here right so the pawns are
on b6 and dsub
yep so what's the quickest way to try to
get to this pawn on b7
um well this square is inaccessible so
it seems this would be the first move
and beyond that so what's the quickest
path to
path to attack the spawn here well
it's probably going to be this way
because i'm guessing
whether black if black's next move is
here i don't have access to this square
right and then after you go to e5 what's
the next square
probably like this okay
and then what's the next square
oh that's not so good why oh wait no
that's actually that's okay
because then black can't take the pawn
they have to go here oh but then i can't
take the black pawn either
so that's a draw it's it's it's not a
draw actually white loses the game
oh okay so but you do see that you do
see the path which is very very good so
like when white goes here
black goes here yep so let's say white
goes back
for example ah
okay i guess let's just flip the board
so you see it from the black perspective
here so what would you play as black
oh let me flip here as
black i mean i think i would still try
to get towards the white pawn
so right now when i go here
right so now i'm going to go here
right and so now i go back
well remember you want to get the
opposition all right
so i'm going to go here yep um
now you don't want to let white get the
opposition
i don't want to let white get the
opposite oh no
um okay so if you push the pawn i just
go back
right okay so i think i go
this way so i'm going to go back
right i go here
so i'm trying to get the opposition
i don't want to let white get the
opposition well remember
what remember the white has the
opposition right now oh right but it's
my
turn okay so i do play pond right so i
go here
okay and then here so i go here
nope um well no i mean i guess in in
this case it works so
when i go here right and now
right so now i have to move my king and
then
right so so you push the pawn and make
the queen again yeah so this is all
about like the opposition and
so if you can just win this pawn with
king f3 it's winning but what white
should try to do is go king here
[Music]
but then what happens is king here white
goes here
black goes here to attack the pawn right
yep and then white goes here black goes
here
right so both kings are guarding the
pawns but based on whose move it is
is what decides the result so let's say
if it's white smooth right you can't
keep the king
protecting the pawn but it seems if
white were to move here
there's a pawn all right
so maybe where does white move that's a
good question to prevent losing the pawn
white can't white basically loses the
game this is what's called zugswong
oh this is too late this has already
been misplayed it's too late at the very
start
actually it's too late the point the
point that i'm that i'm showing is like
what is the path here to try and win
this pawn it's it's one two three four
and try to take the pawn but black is
one two three four
and he protects the pawn oh so you don't
even need it's just a matter of the
counting that we were talking about
before figuring out where the pieces are
right this is just this is a pure cat
this is pure just counting this one
like what is the easiest path for white
to tack upon what's your path to attack
this pawn
yep shorter path for black yeah right so
the number is actually exact same as one
two three four
one two three four but because it's
white's move
it's it's winning um it's winning for
black right
let's say i play the wrong move and we
reach um let me just make a couple
how do i do this let me make some random
moves like
let's say you were to reach this
position for example
and it's black's move now it's losing
because white will capture
yeah right black has to move into a
position where white can capture the
pawn yeah and then white moves the king
and white makes a queen as well
yep so this is wang
is a position where depending on whose
move it is they lose the game they they
can't just wait
they would like to just wait and not
make a move but zuke's long is where
whoever's turn is and they have to make
a move
it's zugswang because they have to make
move and lose the game i think when i
play i'm permanently in zugzwang
i prefer not to make any moves and just
let my opponent make a move that's like
my approach generally right so like this
in
games it really it's it's uh it's one of
those things that matters
matters a lot right so all right so i
think you've looked at a lot of these
these um
we've looked enough these king and pawn
end game so let me let me start a new
board one second so yeah when i do this
i'm taking a file from chess software
and then loading it
onto chess.com we have what are called
pgn files
right so um so i'm just literally taking
it straight out of the chess software
because it's
that's the easiest way um to do it and
there's
that's how there's only been one one bit
of chest software for a very long time
now
do you have notes about players that
would be offensive if they were to be
public
um no i mean i think certainly chess is
a game where when you get really good at
it
there's a lot of ego in it you have to
really think that you're better than
your opponents so i wouldn't say it's in
the notes but i think all players at
certain times we have certain
opinions about the people we're playing
against that are not exactly uh
not exactly fantastic not exactly uh
politically correct
got it got it so
all right so you see this position this
is uh white has a rook
and four pawns black has a rook and
three pawns yep
um so one thing that you want to do is
like
the same game it's not necessarily about
knowing the exact pattern to win
but one thing that's important to think
about is the rooks here
and when you're in a rook and pawn end
game and you have like an extra pawn
that
this is what we call a pass bomb by the
way i don't know if i explained that but
a passport is where there's nothing
impeding the progress
of the pond
got it oh yeah that i know so like if
you look at these three pawns there
none of these are past pawns because
there's a pawn in the way but this is a
pass pawn
that if it could it would just go all
the way up the board and make it clean
so when you have rooks on the board in a
position like this
um and you're trying to uh you're trying
to
sort of get this pawn up the board the
most important thing to remember
as is where do you want your rook to to
make help put
a score at the pawn of the board okay so
i mean i guess i would first think about
rook to a1
um and then i would try to move the pawn
up and then i guess the black rook
could i guess you would need the king
right black would need to bring the king
in if they want a shot at stopping me
right so so let's say that you make a
check and you and you try to promote the
pawn like this
yep and i go rook here yep
is this a good setup for the rook of
scoring the pawn up the board or not
it seems like it's not because at some
point i have to get the rook out of the
way the rook can't attack diagonally so
at some point
it seems the pawn will be unprotected
right so what for example
yeah i just keep waiting and if you ever
move the rook out of the way i take the
pawn
right your rook becomes a very passive
piece it can't move here
and i have no other check or anything
that i could do
right so so you you were right at the
start but i just wanted to show
why why why that is so if you have a
position like this
um it's always better if you can get the
rook behind the pawn
rather than having the rook in front of
the pawn or having to work on the side
like even a position like this
is not fantastic because you can't you
can't really move the rook up just keep
escorting the pawn up the board and make
it right because if you everybody look
up i just take the pawn
that makes sense so what you want to do
here is yeah you want to go rook here
and the reason that this is so powerful
is because now i can't get the rook
behind the pawn
in in in like in a perfect world for
black you always want to attack this
pawn from behind
rather than from in front so for example
it's always better that it's behind the
pawn like here
than say if you have the rook um than
the rook in front of the pawn
and why is that just because i can
defend by putting my rook behind
yes because what happens is when you um
let me go back is that when you put the
rook on a1
what happens here like let's just say i
move my king
i i think i just start moving with pond
right and so if you if you were black
how do you stop the pawn from coming all
the way up the board here
um
i mean i guess you go here right so
that's the only way to stop the pawn but
the problem is that now once you push
the pawn all the way up the board
um the rook is the rook is stuck here
yep
so basically the the black rook is stuck
and the white rook always guards the
pawn
so again conceptually if you want if you
want to help get this pawn to the end of
board and make a queen
how would you do that because you can't
you can't really move the rook or the
pawn anymore
um well the pawns only go forward so i
guess it has to be
something with the king right so where
yeah so this isn't about split moves
where would you like your king to be
if you could get it to a certain square
uh here
exactly yeah that's perfect so like in a
perfect world if i just keep
waiting around um you would just bring
the king up
and at some point the rook has to give
itself up you're going to push the queen
and capture the rook
um or you're just going to get another
queen now could it become a king race to
get up to this square if
if the black king instead of moving back
and forth was trying to race me over
there
right and that's that's what it should
become so after after um
after rook a1 here what black the first
thing black should do is black should
move the rook here
and the reason is that when you push the
pawn i stop the pawn on this square
rather than the seventh ring it's closer
to the king in some sense
yes but it's also further away from the
queening square like the further up the
board the pawn gets the harder it
becomes to defend this position
yeah so so now now you don't really want
to move the pawn or the rook
so now i guess you go with the king
right
right and so now i'm gonna just move my
king over
okay i'm gonna move my king here
and now okay this this is this is this
is to advance this next move so i'm not
really gonna
uh i expect you to plan this move but
but what you do here is you can play a
waiting move with your rook
right right and so now what happens when
i bring my king over because i'm trying
to capture this pawn right
yep but can you prevent that
can i prevent it okay so is it just
another
one s square rook move no it doesn't
really help
right so what happens here now that the
king has gone over towards his pawn
you can bring your king closer oh
because what happens when black captures
well i guess if we trade here now i've
got
i've got access to these pawns and black
the black king is too far from my pawns
right it's one two three and i need one
two three four
like five moves yeah so your king gets
over and captures all these pawns
um immediately right so
so that's how that's how you would win
this game is basically when
when uh you got an active rook and your
opponent has a passive rook like this
your opponent's gonna have to bring
their king close to the pawn because
when you bring your king close if you
get the king next to the pawn you're
just then the pawn is going all the way
off the board immediately
and so when your opponent brings the
king all the way over then you now use
your king you go the other way
towards black's pawns so the idea
basically is
try to get the my rook behind the pass
pawn
force black to have to defend with the
rook start bringing my king
in and then if black's king gets over
extended then i
go the kind of concede concede the rook
trade and move the king where
i'm going to want it after that trade
right exactly
because basically it comes down to think
of it this way think of the active rip
versus the passive rook so like
if if your rook ends up if your rook
ends up like in front of the pawn your
rook is very passive because it can't
move away it only can move up and down
but the black rook meanwhile can can
attack the pawn but it can also attack
sideways as well
you see how like the black work is very
active totally it's not it's not like
it's not just stuck here it's attacking
vertically and also horizontally so
um whereas the white rook is just like
it's passive because it's it's
basically stuck to these three squares
guarding the pot yes
so when you put the rook behind the pawn
i mean it might look like your rook is
passive but you actually make black
sword kept to become very passive
and stuck behind the pawn here where it
can't move so your your rook action can
still go side to side like if the king
comes close
there might be some ideas to check the
king even
but the black work is very passive here
whereas if the if the rook uh
if the rook can get behind the pawn like
on a2 here then black's work is very
active and your rook becomes
past sure that makes sense
so yeah i think that's um that that's
the main thing about this end game is
that when you get to the rook and the
rook and pond
like rook and pawn end games if you have
an extra pawn that's that's uh that's
active or you pass a pawn or you can get
the
the rook behind the pawn it's always
good if you can make your opponent's
rook become passive and your rook be
active
so generally in a situation where it's
a rook on each side and four versus
three pawns
is it always winnable for the side that
has the four pawns or can you have a
situation where it would not be because
of the
the placement so so most rook and pawn
end games where you have only rooks
and you only have pawns it's it's
probably a draw with correct play the
vast majority of the time
if you cannot get something like this
with the rook on a1 where it's going to
sport the pawn all the way up the board
even if you have one additional pawn
correct it would end up as a draw okay
so so normally rook and pawn end games
are drawn now for example let me just
make a couple
ignore my moves here let me let me i
mean to be perfectly frank
in the tournament i don't know that
there's going to be perfect play
that no there won't be no i'm just
explaining i'm just explaining a general
thing
right right right and yeah
right no no i was gonna say i also i
think it also
makes sense for me to have some strategy
against what are the likely mistakes
that an opponent would make trying to
defend this position
right so that's why like th this
specific example probably won't occur
but it's very likely you could get into
into a game where there are ideas like
you want to use the rook to help push
the pawn up the board
you end up in those king and pawn and
games where you're trying to um
you're trying to uh you're trying the
opposition matters
because okay one idea is something that
probably will occur at some point during
the event whether you spot or not it's
unclear but just knowing the idea is
is the reason i'm showing this and is
are these moves only relevant when when
really there's very little else left on
the board like if there were some
knights still on the board or a bishop
and
i mean it just it's a totally different
situation right agreed yes yes
it's definitely different this is very
specific to when there are only rooks on
the board
got it okay let me pull up another one
so do you know what do you know about
the rooks on the seventh rank
like double rooks on the seventh have
you heard that phrase i've heard it i
don't i don't
not hugely relevant to my skill level
yet
okay well i guess let me uh invite you
to this board
i would like it to be relevant let me
put it that way
okay
okay so so doubled works on the seventh
means when you have rooks like
rooks like this that are on and they're
connected i've lost to this many times
ah okay that's kind of surprising
because
this happens that often um
so normally it doesn't it really doesn't
matter even like how many pieces on the
board if you can get like two works that
are connected on the seventh ranking
your opponent's king is on this eighth
rank
it's it's generally very deadly if not
outright winning all the time
okay um so this position that i put up
is actually from one of my games i
reversed the colors but i had this
position in actual game and um
so you let me um let me just blunder my
i'm just gonna make some random should i
be looking at this from white or black's
perspective from white's perspective
okay
let me just make some moves so you know
how to make the check made in this
position right
um let's see i mean
so yeah i mean i guess the king in the
middle is what's making me doubt
the first move um
i think this way okay so now the king
can't come back towards the center right
right so when i go here right when i go
here
yeah beautiful easy checkmate with the
two brooks i don't know what you want to
call this pattern but
you know the pattern that's all that
really matters um
so okay let's go back to start so this
is the position i had um from a game
and i know chad is saying we're see rook
c7 rookie seven wins it's not white's
move thank you very much
chat but thank you for the suggestion um
so now
what would you like to do uh to to win
this game like let's just say i moved
the rook here ideally how would you like
to checkmate this black king
where it can't move um
is it to move it in this direction
towards the h file well how would you
try to make a checkmate with the two
rooks so you want to basically use the
rooks to checkmate the king
it's the exact same pattern that you
just saw right so
how would you try to do that with the
two rooks you could do that move
but there's there's a better move so if
you move the rook i just move my king
over and you can't check right so
oh right right right right so how would
you try to do that
to make this check the same same
checkmate with the the brooks
maybe rook here yeah yeah perfect
and so so now the problem is that it's
very hard for me to stop the checkmate
because the rooks are too far away
you're kings right
you can't move three squares and um
so black can play like rook here for
example and the game goes on
um but but you see the idea yes so now
i'm gonna move my knight here
okay so if i move here then there's this
or no that wouldn't really bother
me so okay let's say i move the rook
here well black and play is black can
play
uh chuck yep
and so now when you move the king what i
can do here is i can move my knight back
right and so now you actually can't
capture the knight because my rook
guards knight
yep but much more importantly my king
can now cross it can now come up because
the knight
shields it it covers this this seventh
rank
yep and this actually would be a draw by
the way
at this point this is a draw right
because there's two rooks against the
rook and a knight so if you think about
the end game
if you end up with a rook against um
against a bishop
or a rook against tonight just a lone
rook against the bishop or a lone work
against tonight
it's a draw okay um now let's not say it
would be drawn
in in pog champs but it is a it is a
known drawn end game
and so the same would apply to this end
game with the two rooks against the rook
and the knight
like this would be a draw here or if it
was a rook and a bishop it would be a
draw
but when we look at this this position
after black moves at night
there's actually a very neat idea here
to win the game
and the idea here is that basically i'm
trying to think what you what you would
what you would call this technique but
you can make this check here
okay and black goes king over
and so you see how how in this position
if you move the rook over here for
example black could always move the king
over one square right
and just stop the checkmate yep so what
you can do here is you can make the
check
the king has to go here and you can go
rook here
and so it's like you kind of you force
the king to the center you the king has
to go this way
and now there there's no way he can get
to this this uh this corner here
yep and so let me
let's say i just move my rook here
um hmm
that's interesting i mean
would i want to let me let me just make
a random move i'm going to move my king
here
so now how would you try to check me at
the king do i want to move this way
so if you go that way i go king here uh
okay
and now you can't make the checkmate
right yep
so what's another square you can go to
um
what about here and attack the night in
the meantime also good
um and if i move my king over you could
take the knight yeah but what i was
actually looking for was not so much
this this like this move to try and win
the knight but that you can actually
move the rook further you can you can
split the rooks
oh okay and so now you see the king
can't get over to either side
so wherever wherever the king goes
you're getting checkmated yep
so like if we go back to the this the
start here um
like when i go night here if you ever go
this way my king gets
over to the side where you can't make
the checkmate and then when you come
over i just go
go back yep so
so so what you do is you actually make
the check and when the king gets here
you can now
you can split the rooks you can go rook
here first um
because you have the idea of moving the
rook next move
and then making the background check me
from either side
makes sense it's it's a this is a very
advanced concept
um in terms of knowing to check and then
moving the rook over because normally
what you think of is like
you you want to um you just want to move
the rook and try to checkmate right away
yeah what you do by making this check is
you play this delayed move you
kick the king one square away so it
can't get over to the corner and then
you split the rooks you go over g7 and
then you check me from either side
and there's nothing black could do to
stop that
black can give up material to make the
game go on for more moves but no there's
no way to stop it
okay because how how would you try to
stop it
uh yeah i mean at this point i don't
even know at this point would
so i don't know if black goes
here to prevent that rook from
eventually getting there but then you
just trade rooks on that square
no that you wouldn't want to do that no
no i would not go over i would just go
here
okay i don't have to go all the way over
i just need to make sure that wherever i
split the rooks
that the king can't get to one of these
squares to either of them yeah
right and now i can't stop the checkmate
you can check me from either side
because all because both rooks cover
this rank
makes sense so it's it's just winning um
and
this one isn't really so much about it's
not so much about
remembering this technique because the
technique is very hard but it's more
about remembering that if you can get
these rooks doubled on the seventh rank
with the king on the eighth rank it's
very very dangerous
um and then you can always just you can
always move the rooks apart and then
make the checkmate
um on on this eighth rank and with with
the knight being able to check the king
on multiple squares i'd also want to be
making sure i don't get stuck in a fork
right
right so for example if i move my rook
down and you go rook here
i can go here yeah work your king and
your rook right at the start it's the
same thing
so when i had this position in my in the
game that i played
like a serious professional game against
a very strong israeli grand master
um the reason they moved the knight here
was because they thought they had two
forks in the position
they saw this fork and they also saw
this fork as well
right so there are two forks here but
but the reason it doesn't work is
because again like i said i make the
check
i split the rooks you have no check here
and then i can just i'm free to move the
rook
over and make the checkmate checkmate on
the eighth rank next move
got it so so mainly it's about
remembering
this notion of like if you can get these
double rooks on the seventh to attack um
to to not to attack to make the chuck me
and this is when the king is on the
eighth
right if you can get the double rooks
and it's the same thing by the way for
example it was on the second rank
if you were black and you two rooks it'd
still be called the seventh rank
so it's whenever the rooks are on the
this rank right in front of the king and
the king is on the back line it's called
doubles works on the seventh
and that's very uh it's it's very it's
very powerful
it's not always winning but if you get
the doubled rooks it's very strong just
like
in general and this isn't about end
games um but let's say
let me just make some random moves if
you if you get rooks like this even
if you got double rooks on a file it's
also very strong
um in in middle games like when there
are a lot of pieces on the board if
there's an open line and you can double
your rooks on the open line it's very
strong got it
um and just for my chat since a couple
of people are built
being silly and they're they're they're
they feel like i feel like thinking
they're geniuses after 96 folks
there's rook d seven check hitting the
king in the night black moves the king
and you go work takes night
and thank you very much game over much
appreciated
um so so there is there is no way to
stop the uh
stop the checkmate per se you just lose
material and you resign a few months
later
um but mainly yeah it's just like
knowing that if you get the double rooks
on the seventh like this
it's very strong where there's a king on
the back back uh back rank
got it okay so let's see
are you fall are you following some of
this yeah oh yeah yeah okay
i mean this right here is much less
likely i think
to become usable in one of my upcoming
games than the
than the previous ones which seem more
likely to come up
um but like you said this is a tougher
thing yeah
no i definitely agree with that so let
me see um
okay let's do okay there's there's this
position let me let me pull this up
um so now i'm gonna show you this one
which is uh
this is a rook and pawn end game again
it feels very simple but this is another
end game that i think could occur
potentially or something similar to this
so this is okay
let me invite you to the board
okay so this is a position where black
has a rook in a pawn
versus a rook and and um and the king is
very close to black pawn
so it's white's move here and there's
this technique which is called the it's
called the philidor technique it's a
it's a force uh it's a drawing sequence
where your opponent cannot win the game
um if you if you if you know the correct
moves to play um this was
discovered i think in probably about the
1760s um
in in france uh this technique
so so what what black wants to do in a
perfect world is let's just say
i'm going to set this up differently
here so let's say we get this position
okay um black's trying to push the pawn
and make it queen again as
always um so i'm going to go rook here
black can go let's just say rook here
you move rook here
black makes a check and what happens
when the king comes over
what happens when the king comes over uh
i lose the rook
right i guess this and then i've got to
move
and then i lose the rook right so when i
move the king you just take the rook
yeah so so black wants to keep pushing
the pawn and and the king and then
use the rook to win the game yep so this
technique that's called the
philidor technique this leads to a draw
is you play um
you play rook here so you see how
there's
there's going to be one rank between
when black pushes the pawn there's going
to be this one rank between the kings
yep so when you push the rook up black
cannot bring the king forward because
the rook covers all the squares
and so now when black pushes the pawn
forward he wants to bring the king ahead
and i can stop that by moving my king
well if you move the king what happens
here is i'm gonna check you
yes and when you move the king i can
bring my king down
ah okay yep
so so when you play rook here the moment
black pushes the pawn to help advance
the the king
you can now again this this is again the
technique is the same as uh
same as the other end game it's not the
exact position but what do you want to
do with the rook
how best do you try to attack upon the
king
uh let's see i want to attack if i'm a
white i want to attack from behind
yeah love it
right so how would you do that i guess
maybe here no that's actually that
that's probably too close to the king i
wouldn't want to do that
uh maybe further i don't know back here
right
so now here
right you could do that but actually
what you can also do is you can make the
chuck
okay because what happens is it okay so
let's go back here let's say i block
with the rook
yep in this position you would actually
trade the rooks
uh okay so how would you draw this with
white
um i don't know i mean
i may be here and so when i go here
here right you keep the king opposite
the pawn yeah and so when i go king here
um stay opposite the king
right and when i push back here right
and it's a draw
it's yeah it's a stalemate so
i can't trade the rooks because then it
leads to a draw but when i move the king
you just start checking me all over the
board like when i go here you check and
whenever i block with
the rook you can always just trade and
we reach this end game which is i see
um so like in this position when you put
the rook here if black ever pushes the
pawn you go behind you start making all
the checks
yeah and black can't really do anything
else because if black ever checks you
just move the king
and if black just waits you just keep
waiting all day long on this third rank
and the moment black pushes the pawn to
where there's only this one rank in
between
then you go behind and you may start
making all the checks with the rook
okay and if again if the rook at any
point checks me then i go to the second
rank
right you have to go to the second rank
yeah you keep the king on one of these
two squares
um either opposite the king or opposite
the pawn
got it so me and lisa yeah remember that
the active rook is very very important
in these
end games wow that makes sense
it does it does yeah okay um
okay let's do this this is a little bit
of a simpler one
kind of this is this is very conceptual
this won't probably
i mean most of these rook and pawn
endings probably won't occur but it's
not so much about like knowing the exact
technique
but remembering what the concept is
because the concept will be
important at some point in the event got
it
okay um
okay okay
okay so in this position white has a
rook in two pawns
and black is a rook so if black moves
through
um well let me just make a random let's
say black moves the rook up to attack
the pawn
yeah are there any good moves here
okay let's see so i guess i would think
about either
in no particular order h7
rook to a8 check forcing the king to the
seventh rank
and then when the king has to go i guess
would the king have to go
back to the eighth rank in that case so
okay so so look at these pawns what
squares do these pawns cover here
these pawns cover uh these three squares
right so is there the king can't come up
can it
oh right okay
okay so if i play here right then the
rook has to block
and then and then i take the rook right
and so that's the end of the game got it
so so yeah so in this position uh the
rook can never leave this last ring
because then you move up and you make
the chuck
yeah so i'm just gonna wait with my rook
over here
now the way that you would win this game
well let me start with a first move
which makes sense we just move the rook
up here to guard the pot so there's
never any idea of the black bringing the
king over to win the pawns
right so i'm gonna move my rook here so
how would
how would you in a perfect world if you
could trade the rook sir because you
have two pawns if you have
if you two pawns against the king i
would just say that's all let's just
assume that's always winning if you can
reach king and two pawns versus the king
how would i trade the rook how how do
you try to trade the rooks cause my rook
can't come off the back ranks then i'm
always getting checked
i guess i start moving the king over
okay
uh maybe well i'm looking for a concept
like it's not so much about one move is
better than another move and also when
you reach
end games the moves don't have to be
super precise you just have to have a
concept in mind
because normally with so few pieces your
opponent can't do a whole lot
yeah i mean i guess i start moving the
king over if at any point the rook comes
off of the eighth rank
then i've got that check on and then i
then i'm
kind of forcing uh that previous
position we looked at
right so how would you try to trade the
rooks
because this is the first move sure yeah
like i said it's not about one move you
just have to come up with a concept to
try and trade the rooks
okay now let me think
here well you can't you can't come up
because i'm in oh right yeah right right
right
okay now here
let's go here
okay so to force the trade maybe i come
over here
right so so this is the right the idea
is correct
um but the problem with coming over here
is i can actually just check your king
ah so there's a better move that you can
play here to try and exchange the rooks
it doesn't always have to be on this
specific square
oh okay um maybe here
also good but again i can check your
king okay am i trying to avoid a king
check there
it's not so much you want to avoid the
checks you can still win but there's a
move where i cannot avoid the trade of
the rooks
um so you want to exchange rook on the
eighth rank here
yep
here right and so what happens when i
check now
right and you see if i if i trade the
rooks that's what you want
that's what you want but if i go if i go
like here your next move would be
right and if i go here
right so now i'm going to trade and so
let's see if you can win this end game
okay so let's think about this if i play
here
you could come to this square so i think
here
uh now let me think could you take that
you could
do i play a waiting move
and then
oh i think maybe this well but now i'll
take the pawn oh right now that's not
good support each other
yeah and when you have two pawns that
support like this like remember always
that
the back the backwards pawn here doesn't
matter as much it's only the
as as long as this pawn which is one
square from queening is protected that's
what's most important
so if i move my king closer
is it this way okay and now i go here
right and so now when i take the pawn
right
and then it was um
[Music]
right
right and checkmate exactly that's
that's that's perfect um
so yeah basically the point behind me
showing you this end game is that like
when you have something like this
it's it's there are many there are many
ways to win this but just looking for
the easiest path where your opponent
can't prevent can't prevent the uh
exchange of the rooks where you trans
transpose it into
an end game that you know you'll win 100
times out of 100 times
that concept makes sense so like when
you have the when you when you
just think of it this way if you if you
have two pawns against the king
uh pretty much no matter what that's
going to be a winning end game
like almost no matter what um i don't
actually have this one
let me do a new position setup of that
since that did occur to me just now
um this
okay let's this
okay so i'm gonna set up another one
this is um
it should be yeah king and two pawns
against the king let me invite you to
this one
got it okay so this is this is a
position where you have a king and two
pawns against the king right
yes now if you only now now ordinarily
it's you're going to assume it's not
easy it's not easy to win this end game
because
your pawns are doubled if you if you if
your pawns were just on different
like you had one pawn here on this the
square right next to it and your pawns
were not one in front of the other
for stack like this so it would be very
easy to win
but in this case um it's not so
how what would your move be here if
you're trying to progress forward an
attack
i guess i would i would start moving the
king forward in order to push the black
king back and kind of keep making
progress
right but i'd want to be careful to
avoid eventually
a draw right because at a certain point
if the two pawns get separated
isn't it just the previous draw scenario
well yeah if you were to lose one of the
pawns it is um
so how would you try to escort the pawns
up the board here okay you actually like
to put your king where your pawn is and
then we reach that opposition again
but you can't do that so maybe
this is the first move okay so now i'm
gonna go here
so maybe now i play this pawn okay this
is actually winning but let's let's see
so i go king here
yeah good game thanks for the draw
the black king can't move ah so it's
stalemate
right whereas if there's no pawn you
just use the king of the pawn and you
win the game
right so maybe maybe
so what was the right so here was this
the move
now i go here okay
and then i lose a pond right so actually
the way you would win here is you would
actually push this pawn
oh okay and if you take it then it just
becomes this other end game
what's your next move um okay now
opposition right and now it's black's
move not
white's move yeah so i have to move my
king and your king comes up
um so this would be this would be
winning but the simplest way here is
when i go this way
you can actually go king here okay
and now if i go here what's your next
move now i push the pond
you actually move the king over oh okay
okay because it doesn't matter if you
have one or two pawns
same concept it's the same thing
whichever way my king goes you move the
king off the board and then back over
you make you make this um i don't know
it's like square
triangle whatever but basically yeah you
you you move the king which
the opposite way of black king got it
so here what i would actually place i
would go here i would try to keep the
opposition
and then now i would play the pond
and i know that i don't want to come
here right now wait no
or do i do this this way so so let's
think
the original position with the king and
pawn versus king this this would be a
draw right if you only had one pawn
yep why would this be a draw at the end
of the day like
um like if you only have the king of the
pawn forget about this this one pawn
why is it a draw what happens at the end
of the board
um the king camp the king can't move and
i can't make a queen
right so it's sell me yeah okay but now
think of it this way now you have this
pawn here
yeah you actually can do that you can do
the same you can
do that so let's see if you can figure
out why
so try to try to play it out and figure
out why it's not a draw at the end so
okay right so just force my king to the
end of the board
you can do that but actually i just want
you to go here oh okay
okay so now i'll go here keep the king
offs at the pawn
right so i'll go here
so now i go here okay so now do i start
pushing this other pawn
is that useful at this point no i i mean
i guess here
but that's a draw oh right yeah
no the difference is here you can push
the pot so now i can push the pawn okay
so you can push the pawn one or two
scores it doesn't matter but what
happens is now i have to move my king
right and i can just keep moving the
second pawn
well no that's not what you wanna do you
wanna
oh i see how you make a queen got it
so so like that's the point if you if
you forget about this pawn assuming it's
not on the port it's a draw because you
have to move the king
if you move the king back i just take
the pawn right and i move the king it's
a draw
so when you have this extra pawn even
though it's a double pawn
it's very important because usually when
you push the pawn all the way down the
board
you can that you can then like waste a
move you can push this pawn so the king
has to move and then you move your king
up and make the queen crystal clear
somewhat yeah yeah i mean i don't really
want it
overload too much so i think that's
probably a pretty good spot to stop with
the end games um
uh but like do you have like specific
questions like about these end games or
in general
no i mean with these i think it's just
repetition and really getting down the
patterns
and then keeping in mind that the the
posit i have to add to the position
whether it's my turn or my opponent's
turn and that that actually changes the
scenario
right that it's very important um but i
think it's
like it's it's most important um just
like the concepts like remembering like
when you reach these end games like if
you end up with these two pawns like
even though you you think the pawn
behind pawn here on b2 doesn't matter
much
um it does because you can waste you can
sort of like waste the tempos and
force the king to go where it where it
doesn't want to go here right
um and and so like this one with like
using the pawn or the other one where
you're trying to exchange the brooks or
the king opposition i think um
i i would say that that rook a1
especially the rook and four versus the
rook and
three that's the one that's the one
concept that's going to be
most important um to remember for the
event because that's the one that's most
likely to occur
some of these things could occur but
probably you're not going to get it
where it's a simplified version because
in order for it to be relatively close
like this players have to be the same
level
um because otherwise someone's going to
be up like five pounds in this end game
and and just a
straightforward win but i think that's
important and then also the the double
brooks one
remembering that if you can double the
rooks with the king on the back rank
that's almost
always deadly
then you split them right and then you
you make that that checkmate
yeah the separate rooks so so i think
it's
i mean i think you're on you're on a
great path you've definitely looked at
openings you have good general
understanding i think across
all all phases of the game but just
repeating a little bit um
some i think some of these basic end
games will also be very helpful because
when you
you're you're going to make it into
you're to keep it real you're going to
be in the
you're going to be in the champions
bracket like you're one of those i am
not
listen uh i wish i was as confident as
trump is that he's going to lose
and i wish i was as confident at you are
as you are that i'm going to be in this
uh champion champions bracket
okay at any rate you're going to play
against players who are uh
who are who are around your level at
some point
and so some of these even positions
you'll get these even material positions
deeper in the game as opposed at the
very start so got it
um so that's why i think these concepts
should be important
is your sense that the level of the
players in the tournament is relatively
even
um for the most part yes i think there
are a couple players who need to work
really really hard to catch up but
overall i feel that
they're i would say you're one of the
favorites they're probably about like
five to six people who are who are
working quite diligently
um and then some of some players who
have to work harder but you're you're
you're definitely in that like
i would say the top four to five for
sure and it's 16 total
16 total um eight players there are
eight players who go into the top
bracket and eight players who go into
the
the bottom bracket right um and the top
two
from each group make it in so it'll be
four groups of four players top two
in groups a b c d make it in the
championship bracket and then third and
fourth go into the bottom bracket
and are all 16 players have been
announced right yes they
we yeah i announced them earlier on the
stream most had already been announced
but the last two were announced on oh
there were new
who was announced today oh i don't even
know then um forest foursome was
announced and i believe the other one
was call me carson
oh my god i don't know who any of these
people are i feel like i'm completely
out culturally of what's happening
i don't know i mean like they're they're
they're big streamers but but
again they're they're they're just
streamers
okay i don't want anybody taking offense
i mean i'm sure they don't know who i am
either you know what i mean like it's
all fine it's no no big deal yeah yeah
i think it's like there always are some
people who know each other some who
don't but like
it's it's all good i think it's just
like everyone's trying to learn the game
and have fun and i think that's
that's that's what counts i i know from
like being on just being on twitch last
like two years it's it's amazing to see
all the different
categories and what everyone is doing
and and it's just it's great to see so
many people from different backgrounds
so it's not like
you know it's not like there's you for
example and like hassan and like all
and destiny and all the political guys
it's like it's this nice nice mix um
from from like
all these different different games yes
steve steven kenneth destiny benell the
second would be an interesting player
in the tournament uh yeah i mean you i
like i feel like your
politics and the way you explain things
is a little bit better honestly
really oh my god clip that jeez holy
[ __ ] we've gotta clip that
thing that's shocking just saying uh
yeah he he is actually quite decent at
shots but
i i um i i like i like your
politics more wow i'm flattered oh my
god that's going to be in the new david
pakman show trailer
yeah i i tend to lean left anyway so i
like i like what i see hey so one thing
i wanted to ask you about
completely out of context at some point
i came across
a video of it was a video actually of a
different game at a tournament and you
just happened to be sitting next to the
game that was going on
and you're like giving this side eye to
something that's going on and just
looking
looking over at some other player who i
didn't recognize like they were
like they had committed a crime of some
kind what what was
the story with that i just don't i'm
just not good enough at chess to know
what happened that was so offensive
so it's it's not even that it was
offensive uh so
just so my chat knows there's this
tournament that i played in gibraltar
uh i think it was last year and the guy
who was playing on the board next to me
he was formerly the number two ranked
player in the world he's an extremely
strong super grand master
and he was playing against the player
who's a little bit weaker obviously guys
still
extremely another extremely strong grand
master but someone who
most people would not say is in the same
same category as he is and basically
he the the guy that i've seen next to
really the former world number two
he played an opening that was dubious he
he basically made a sacrifice that was
not
sound he sacrificed tonight i think it
was um when he shun tab and so he was
completely losing in the game
and the reason i gave that look is
because having having known the guy for
so many years having played against him
in many events
i i have a lot of respect for him i
think he's one of the best players in
the world
and so to see him playing like that is
just one of those things where it's like
dude what are you doing
like you're such a great player and i
look over and he's just losing this game
terribly
and had you been watching the game the
whole time as you were playing or did
you look and see the position and
identify that it was wacky
yeah so one thing that chas players do
is when you play these long
long games of chess um you have long
periods where your opponent is thinking
because you can think like 20 or 30
minutes on a move and so periodically
you're looking at the board next to you
or you get up and you look at the other
board so you're always
sort of paying attention because in the
modern age with technology
you're looking to see what sort of
opening strategies people are playing
and so i was i was watching the game on
and off and then then at some point i i
there was a period when i was thinking
at my board probably 20 25 minutes
and then i looked over again it's like
the position had gone from something
that i thought was interesting
just kind of normal to something that
was terribly losing for uh
for for for this this guy i know so
and is it is it considered um is it
considered a crass
or or a rude to be caught looking like
that over at
you know another board or is it just
sort of like no big deal in the chess
community
it's not really a big deal i think it's
i mean perhaps a little bit more
exaggerated
than it should have been but there are
definitely times when when
top grand masters they look at games and
they will definitely give some people
these looks like
what are you doing um there's another
there's this there's this dutch grand
master for example i know who
very frequently when he sees somebody
play an opening that he doesn't think is
good or he doesn't have respect for it
he will sort of give this the stare um
so it is pretty common to have some to
have some
uh expressions and mannerisms when
people do things that you don't really
you aren't expecting guy i gotcha okay
that's that's uh that's good to know
yeah that's a that's a wild moment out
of context if you don't know what's
going on it's you know it's like
something strange just
clearly is happening here right yeah
it's it's basically like it's like as my
chat
it's really bro what are you doing like
you just don't expect it because the top
players are so consistent
and they generally play such great chess
that it's just very it's just
surprising when you see it happen i just
i was shocked it was i was shocked
that you were so shocked let me put it
that way you know what i mean
yeah i think it's like to give some
context the guy who made the blunder the
former world number two
i've probably known him for i would say
20 years or they're about so i've been
very familiar i've seen his games from
the time he was he was a young junior
player to becoming a professional
i'm an adult so like when you when you
have such respect you've seen so many
games
players have played uh over such a long
career they're just sometimes you see
these things it's like
well if they do this why can't they do
that against me or what like what's
what's going on
my only other real question chess
related was
what is it i've been watching a little
bit of is it anish or anishkiri
something about his personality on these
streams is extremely compelling like i
find it
strangely entertaining and there's i
mean you just it's not where you see him
and you're like
he would be the most fun person to have
a beer with it's not that type of thing
but it's like something about his
demeanor is strangely compelling
hmm interesting um yeah i think anisha
is very charismatic the
sort of he's he's certainly one of the
guys who has more charisma i would say
um
in in the chess world he's one of the
guys who can say things that are more
sort of off the cuff he can be very
entertaining
um and i think in the chess world it's
fairly rare to have people who are
entertaining
and can sort of like put context or give
some perspective on a lot of different
things
and just the way that he he uh he
handles social media for example
is not not common either like he's very
brashy he
he writes a lot of sort of um what's the
way of putting he
he writes a lot of sort of messages that
generate like
responses it's very like sort of out
there and in your face so
he's he's he's one of the one of the
people who's most fun to watch for sure
in the chess world
obviously english isn't his first
language but like what what are the
rules about that at tournaments because
i remember some controversy about i
don't remember who it was said
magnus said something in norwegian
and then it was like had that been true
are there rules where it's like the
tournament says this is the default
language or is it just
english i mean pretty much everybody
speaks english for the most part um
like not even as a first language but i
i think people plenty of times have have
cursed in other languages but generally
everybody speaks english so
like if if you talk to people um i would
i would say
it's probably like i would say 80
percent of people speak english
um and then probably i don't know
probably like
a large percentage i want to say like
maybe 70 they'll either speak english or
they'll speak russian those are by far
and away the two most um
two most popular languages but is it a
is it a written rule that it's english
only at the
chess boards or something like that um
i mean you're not you're not supposed to
you're not really
supposed to to talk during this oh at
all oh okay
okay yeah it's just that i mean i i
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but generally you just you
just you aren't supposed to talk
i didn't realize that i guess that makes
sense because it's like what would you
really talk about during the game
right because you're trying to focus and
and beat your opponent
um but but yeah also in in terms of that
specific story though
um the reason that it became an issue is
because both players are very low on
time so when someone says something
it can be very distracting since you're
not supposed to talk and and since it
was a blitz game
um between magnus and and a very young
junior player from iran
it was just one of those things that
you're not really expecting so when it
happened it kind of caused a little bit
of controversy have you i don't
if if you just want to pass on this by
all means but
have you taken a position on remind me
the name of the young iranian player
his name is ali raza farouja right have
you taken a position on his decision to
uh essentially become be french play as
a french player
in order to not be bound by these
iranian rules about not playing
with uh israeli players yeah i think i
think there are a couple things i will
say
there are quite a few iranians i know
who have actually left the country
um uh for many for many reasons i
there are several female players that
i've spoken to over the years who have
left because of the issue with the hijab
um and ali reza leaving as well because
of the issue with
trying to improve and play against
israeli players so so what i would say
in in general terms on the topic
is that um when you're young you're
trying to improve and play the game of
chess
you you really you want the most
opportunities to to just
get out there and play the game play
against everybody play against the best
competition and
when you have these rules that the
iranian i mean basically iranian
government has instituted where you are
not able to um compete against israelis
whether it's chess
whether it's martial arts olympic sports
and all these other different activities
um
it's sort of it makes it very difficult
because then like in chess
where you don't have have all the
opportunities you really need
invitations to tournaments
organizers are not necessarily going to
um uh
invite players if they're playing for
iran because it causes controversy
and there are quite a few very strong
israeli players as well
and um and so it's just one of those
situations which is very unfortunate but
in terms of ali reza he's one of the
most talented junior players that we've
seen
in a very long time um and for him to
come out of a country like iran which
they do try to support chess but they
don't have a really strong
um chess background or culture top
players coming out of that country who
are so strong who are potentially going
to compete for the world championship
um it's again you want to have the most
opportunities so
it's it's a shame that things like this
happen but again i know quite a few
people
who have left the country i feel like uh
i mean i try not to be political but i
think
i think certainly there's a bit of a
brain drain going on there and a lot of
people
um have been forced to leave the country
it's really it's really a shame
it's it's it's a great tragedy it is it
is yeah it's quite
quite a situation made it made uh some
headlines even in uh
my work not even to use that example but
there's someone else i know
and um who i'm who i'm friends with i
saw a post that they made
um and it's someone who who's she's
female and
she made a post um and it was a joke but
she made the post that if she returned
to iran
basically her i mean her head would be
on a platter
basically um and when you see those
sorts of things like
it really i think puts it into context
just how serious
these situations are um in countries
like iran
when you know you think about these
stories you hear these stories but it
doesn't really hit home until you
actually
hear about people who have sort of had
to leave and like if they ever were to
return i mean they would they would
they would be killed and it's it's just
yeah it's
it's it's unfortunate but i think it
puts it into context that despite all
the stuff that
that's going on here here right now
there there are certainly our place
where things are a lot lot worse
no doubt no doubt yeah that's the that's
the important context i think
well listen um i so appreciate the time
um i uh i'm going to be working on all
of these things very powerfully
and continuing a strict training regimen
do you recommend any physical
exercise in particular like for example
are push-ups better than pull-ups to
prepare for chess or anything like that
i don't think that's that that shouldn't
really play a role i mean i think
like the main thing is like do you
do like mentally do you get tired
quickly or not
first off i mean i guess it depends
compared to who
i mean like i guess if you were to focus
on not even chess specifically but
something
that's mental for like like a game for
example for like an
hour or two would you get tired quickly
or not well listen video games i just
they bore me so i just would never play
them for two hours but certainly i mean
today listen i produced my entire
90-minute show did a two-hour stream and
then now we've been doing this close to
two hours
and i don't feel like oh my god i gotta
go to bed or anything like that
yeah then i think it's then i wouldn't
even worry if you if you have energy
then it's not it shouldn't play a role
um
because you're not you're not gonna be
playing for more than probably
an hour your match will be two games so
it won't be more than one hour when
you're playing
your match so it shouldn't really
shouldn't really matter got it
okay okay i mean listen if you can sit
through people saying maybe
inject uh a bleach into your body and
not have to immediately abort
maybe a 10-minute chess game is
something i could do you know yeah yeah
of course i mean it's it's yeah it's
crazy world out there but i
i i like what you do and it's great that
you're competing in this event um
just i hope you have fun and i'm sure
i'm sure i can help you during the event
as well once it gets going because
people will probably be wanting lessons
as well so if you want to do this again
just let me know oh
i'm available yeah no thanks to you and
every all the coaches have been great
and
i uh you know i hope your your viewers
did not find themselves totally
disgusted with my presence on your
stream today
no i i think i think everybody enjoyed
it so it was a lot of fun and uh
we should do it again all right thank
you so much i'll talk to you soon great
no problem talk to you soon all right
all right see ya
bye all right wow
i'm lying i'm exhausted from that i've
got to go immediately to bed
no i'm kidding um that that was really
great and we're gonna post that
definitely
to youtube and uh just i mean just
wild wild stuff is happening here um
from the standpoint of the tournament i
do want to say thanks to
king d pie for the twitch prime
subscription
oh gotha i just i didn't even realize
levy raided me with a party of 307 i
just missed it completely i appreciate
that
we're going to do something again soon
um
zack caddy and i'm being asked
to raid actually the serfs yeah
let's raid the serfs um that's a small
ish channel no offense or anything and
we want to support them so let's do it
let's do it we're going to raid the
surfs we're going to raid lance i'm
going to go over
and make sure i'm watching that myself
and i think it's going to be very very
exciting all right ready guys here we go